with lockdown life in full effect we
don't get to see our favorite celebs
walking the streets in the latest
fashion trends anymore
but one thing that quarantine life has
brought us is a totally new side of
celebrities and their new stay-at-home
Styles we're taking a look at quarantine
life and how much it's changed these
celebrities looks and you'll be shocked
to see the differences this is what it's
come to the bangs are too long can't go
outside we are used to seeing dojo
seawood decked out in lots of sparkles
glitter and some outrageously colorful
outfits and of course she always dons
her signature side ponytail
however while being in isolation she's
toned it down a whole lot and even let
her hair down say what the former dance
moms star tried an all-natural look that
had not a single sparkle on her outfit
but for all the Jojo fans out there
don't worry she's not getting rid of her
signature look any time soon the YouTube
star said that she's just giving her
hair a much-needed break another
celebrity changing up their hairstyles
during quarantine is Maddie Ziegler
we're used to seeing the talented dancer
with light brown hair and even blonde
streaks and she always looks great but
the famous teen decided to change things
up from her regular hair color and add a
touch of pink she doesn't seem too happy
with the results though what do you
think of her pink accents at least this
next celebrity hasn't gone too far from
her normal look Lily Reinhardt knows
what works for her and has always
followed the latest trends flawlessly in
pre quarantine life even her character
Betty Cooper has a sweet and simple
style that is fashion trendy but it
looks like at home the Riverdale star is
switching in her signature Betty Cooper
ponytail and miniskirts for some French
braids sweats and a pair of flip-flops
it's a much more relaxed look but we're
liking her comfy style I just print
willing to try anything as a super
successful high-fashion model it is no
doubt that kendall jenner style is
always on point as part of the
kardashian-jenner clan stepping out in
front of paparazzi it's crucial to
always look ones best but in quarantine
life
has been taking it easy walking her dogs
and deciding to lighten her hair she's
going for a more laid-back natural look
now that she's been staying home and
relaxing
this next stars quarantine look is
actually not much different from her
regular appearance at home anyways
YouTube star Emma Chamberlain often can
be seen in her online videos with no
makeup and dressed down and comfy sweats
with a messy bun in her hair however
before isolation you'd see her in trendy
and stylish clothes from time to time
known for her I don't care what anyone
thinks persona Emma's not afraid to show
who she really is
the girl is always keeping it real I
think of myself as a very normal 18 year
old girl and in her new Quarantine life
it looks like she's keeping it very
natural and definitely real with this no
makeup selfie did you know that Ariana
Grande's natural hair is not even
straight the pop singer actually has
curly brown hair but rarely where is it
that way we've seen her hair go from
bright red in the early days of her
career starring on the Nickelodeon show
Victorious why would you do that to your
hair
what you mean the color to eventually
evolving into her a high long ponytail
that we see her wearing today but the
truth is the girl's got some nice curls
we wonder if she'll eventually free
those curls for good if she ever wants
to reinvent herself or change her image
until then we'll just have to enjoy her
pretty curls from afar while she stays
inside during quarantine another
celebrity that is letting her natural
hair free is a grown --is-- star Yara
Shahidi
the actress always has impeccable style
whether she is walking down the city
streets or working on set of her TV show
we often see the actresses hairstyles as
either pulled back or pinned up so when
she recently shared a photo of herself
on Instagram it was nice to see her in
this bare face selfie keeping it natural
and letting her beautiful curls loose
this self-made billionaire has
definitely evolved her fashion from her
early days on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
now Kylie Jenner has become a fashion
trendsetter a makeup mogul and she is
killing it like you took something and
turned it into this Empire we are used
to seeing her in glitz and glam with big
pouty lips and different colored
hairstyles but it looks as though
Quarantine life has made Kylie soften
her style for a more natural look with a
bare face and no extensions just Kylie
her short hair and her cute avocado top
next is a celebrity who never cares what
other people think and is always
experimenting with her own individual
style Miley Cyrus who in recent years
has had style evolved from can't be
tamed to a wrecking ball in fashion and
now it seems she's finally found some
balance and although her fashion can be
over-the-top for some it's nice to see
her play around with her own distinct
style and personality Quarantine life
hasn't stopped her from having fun
either she admitted in an Instagram live
video on her series bright minded that
she cut her own hair and gave herself
bangs not bad Miley in the old world
back when we all walked around hugging
and kissing and shaking hands with one
another Vampire Diaries star Nina Dobrev
stepped out in a style that rarely
missed the mark her fashion sense has
always been pretty spot-on and she
always looked flawless it's not everyday
the brunette beauty is seen in her
sporty casual wear topped with a messy
hair bun updo but that is the effects of
Quarantine life and we're digging it our
next star style change was done all in
the name of charity Kacie COTS aka Kevin
Keller from the Netflix series Riverdale
normally Dawn's perfectly styled hair at
a much longer length however the actor
decided to shave it all off alongside
his brother to raise money for a
nonprofit organization called charity
water they called the fundraising
campaign the cot quarantine cut and are
aiming to raise $20,000 during
quarantine if you want to donate
go to the link in either one of our BIOS
another celeb going au naturale is
Hayley Beaver in quarantine she's been
rocking her natural and glowing skin
normally the successful model and
influencer is seen wearing some of the
most beautiful clothes in high fashion
but Sinn féin at home for the last
several weeks
it looks like Hayley has replaced her
Haute Couture for a more natural and
comfortable look just check out this
photo of her wearing no makeup and
sporting a simple Nike headband nois
Antonio changed up his look not too long
after his movie all the boys I loved
before too came out sometimes I wish my
boyfriend was more anonymous the actor
shaved his gorgeous hair to have barely
their length and he is pulling it off
really well since quarantine it seems
he's changed it up even more looks like
he hasn't just been social distancing
from people lately but also his razor no
I can be seen in a photo from his
Instagram showcasing a quarantine beard
turns out that's actually a thing we
wonder how long he'll grow it out what
do you think of noah's new beard when
shawn mendes steps out onto any red
carpet he is always dressed to impress
the cutie patootie singer's fashion is
always clean and fresh with his wavy
brown hair perfectly styled Shawn style
seems to be effortlessly pairing with
his natural good looks and perfect brown
hair unfortunately it looks like
Quarantine life and the Miami Heat
are messing up his luscious locks and
he's gone from looking flawless to
looking totally frizzy it's just
reacting to the heat right now yeah it's
getting curly creamy looks like another
celeb got a haircut during quarantine
Camila Cabello got her bangs trimmed by
her mom the former fifth harmony member
has stepped up her fashion game since
leaving the girl group and has evolved
her look into a classier style but asked
for her new quarantine look she is
keeping it simple haircuts and jam
sessions seem to be her new normal with
none other than her beau Shawn Mendes
his frizzy hair and her short bangs are
a quarantine match made in heaven
not that bad I'll show you guys my
drives up celebrities like dual eepa
whose passion for fashion is clearly
seen in everything she wears might be
having a hard time not getting the
chance to show off her bold and colorful
outfits and although she might not get a
chance to dress up like she used to it
doesn't mean she can't have a little fun
the singer decided to change up her dark
brown hair and add some pink to the mix
we love how even at home she is still
trying different things with her look
one star whose new Quarantine style is a
much stress exchange from what he
usually looks like is Liam Payne the
face of Hugo fragrances and former One
Direction singer has quite the style in
his regular public life however his new
Quarantine look has us confused with a
computer tech guy from the 1980s with
those overly large glasses tacky
corduroy jacket and his grown out
hairstyle it's a big change from his
usual clean-cut look we are used to
seeing him in so yeah I mean as you
probably already guessed I am just
chilling at home Hilary Duff has always
kept up with the latest in fashion even
created her own clothing line called
stuff by Hilary Duff we think Quarantine
life has inspired her to experiment with
her look and more so her hairstyle
the former Lizzie McGuire star decided
to change up her signature long blond
locks for a shorter blue hair style and
we are loving the new transformation do
you think she pulls off this blue do
normally singer Katy Perry steps out in
the most colorful and sometimes
over-the-top outfits her fashion style
has evolved over the years but still
remains pretty wild sometimes however it
looks like during quarantine this mama
savvy is toning it down and keeping it
simple with her short blond hair and
natural face we wonder if she will keep
up this natural look after quarantine
ends
when Luke Hemmings first stepped into
the limelight he looked like he was
straight out of an Abercrombie & Fitch
ad you could say he looked so perfect
as time passed his style has evolved
with him in recent months the 5 seconds
of summer singer has grown out of his
hair and has kept his curly brown locks
swept back or to the side of his face
but it looks like being stuck at home
has inspired him to try something new
and the lead singer looks almost
unrecognizable in his bleached blond
messy Kurt Cobain look and were all for
it
life and isolation has shown us a whole
other side to these stars with their new
looks it is a big difference from their
usual glitz and glam in the public eye
these celebrities are trying to make the
most of their time while stuck inside by
changing things up a little what do you
think about their new quarantine looks
is it a nice change from what we're used
to seeing or can you not wait for them
to step out once again in their high-end
trendy fashions my body looks crazy like
I need to kind of suffocate before you
go give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time on the things thanks
for watching